this is a question related to geometric
progressions as is going to become clear
really soon and there's going to be kind
of two parts to this explanation we got
to set up the question first and that
actually takes a fair bit of thought and
attention and then we're gonna have a
look at two different ways to solve this
problem each of which kind of ends up
being equivalent we'll arrive at the
same answer but each one has different
kind of pros and cons so they'll become
clearer as we start to go through the
question says when light passes through
one shade of very thin glass its
intensity is reduced by 3% that seems
important I'm gonna highlight that I've
used by three percent what's the minimum
number of sheets that's also pretty
important the minimum number of sheets
that will reduce the intensity below 1%
all right so let's start to have a think
about this now when we have a think
about this question it's not immediately
apparent that this is a series and
sequence question but sort of the setup
of how we interpret this and translator
into language that we can manipulate
shows that it's a geometric series now I
guess what we can say see immediately is
that there's a number of sheets that
we're going to set up and each one is
successively going to make a difference
to the amount of light intensity and
that's kind of what gives us this
geometric progression situation so
here's what I'm going to suggest first
we've noticed that each layer of glass
each sheet it reduces the light by three
percent which is another way of saying
that it lets through an intensity of
ninety seven percent so each time you
pass through a new sheet of glass this
is how much kind of light survives it
makes it through right now after I can
work out well how much sort of happens
what sort of light intensity gets
through one sheet and the two sheets and
in three sheets I can sort of establish
a pattern and then I can build a
geometric progression from there so if
we say you know let's call T n the nth
term the amount of light the intensity
after while you pass through some number
of sheets so the intensity of light
after n sheets and being our number of
sheets if we define T event that way
then we can start to say well what would
the first term be after you pass through
a single sheet how much light gets
through we've already established that's
97% I could keep on writing everything's
in percentages but I'm actually going to
rewrite that percentage as a decimal
it's just going to make it a teeny bit
easier as we progress through the rest
of this when I'm entering this into my
calculator I try to avoid interacting
directly your percentages it's a bit of
a hassle so this is how much light 0.97
or 97% that gets through the first layer
when I think about what happens through
the next layer I start with this amount
of light 97% and I reduce it by 3% so
only 97 percent of the 90% makes it
through so in other words I've got that
97% that I started with but then I've
got to multiply that by 97% or at 0.97
I've got to do that again so you can see
here I'm starting to establish this
pattern I had zero point nine seven to
the power of one now I've got to the
power of two when I pass through a third
sheet well no surprise
you've got the 97% from the first two
sheets you multiply that by 97% again
and so we have zero point nine seven or
cubed now once you've got one two three
lines set up three terms in your
progression that's kind of enough to say
alright dot a number of things will
happen
I can now generalize to what the nth
term will be I'm just gonna match up you
can see the first term has one lot of
0.97 the second term has two lots two
two times we multiply by and then lastly
the third term it's got realize that's
kind of nice and convenient sometimes
you have to be careful with whether
you're N minus 1 or n plus 1 but in this
case you're N exactly lines up with the
power that's there so I can generalize
the nth term as 0.97 to the power of M
all right so this is the intensity of
light after n sheets this is my
expression for it
that's dependent on n so let's just
return to the question it says what's
the minimum number of sheets the minimum
number of shades that will reduce the
intensity below 1% we highlighted this
before
so very very literally I can just say
well I want to find n such that here's
the question right such that the nth
term zero point seven to the power of n
I want it to be less than one percent
below one percent so I'm gonna write
that as zero point zero one because I'm
writing everything in decimals okay now
at this point I'm gonna hit pause I've
set up the question I've sort of created
this model I've got algebra now and
really it's up to me now that I've
translated all of this word or this
verbiage stuff into my symbols and sort
of expressions I can now decide how I'm
gonna solve this and there's at least
two different ways that I could go about
this so I'm going to show you each one
in turn and then we can think about the
advantages and disadvantages of each so
here comes method one what I'm gonna do
is I'm going to think about this as an
inequality and I'm going to solve it
leaving it as an inequality all the way
through so here's my first thing that I
noticed I want to solve for and there it
is up there in the top so in order to
get that in out of the power the topic
the knowledge the concept I need to sort
of grab a hold of that takes things out
of a power and brings them out of there
and makes it easier to handle the thing
that I need to use is logs right so what
I can do is take logs of both sides of
this inequality now I can choose any
base that I like I'm going to choose the
natural log Ln that's the base of e
because it's on my calculator it's easy
to access so I'm gonna take log of the
left hand side that gives me this and
then I take log of the right hand side
which gives me this okay now what I want
to do is make n this subject so I'm
gonna use one of the log laws I know the
power law which enables me let's change
color which allows me to take this power
and bring it out the front as the
coefficients so I'm gonna write the next
line as n
log 0.97 is less than log 0.01 okay this
is really great because I'm really only
a couple of steps away from getting a
complete answer because that n is just
kind of sitting there and I need to just
isolate it now you're probably thinking
I need to now divide both sides by this
log 0.97 because that will enable me to
get in on its iron and I am going to do
that I'll end up with N on the left hand
side and I'll end up with log 0.01 that
was already there on the right hand side
divided by log 0.97 but I'm hesitating
before I complete this line because he
is the first sort of danger when you use
this first method the inequality when
you divide both sides or multiply both
sides of an inequality you have to pay
attention to what direction inequality
will land in now most of us look at that
and say yeah no problem I can just
divide through by that doesn't cause any
issues but in fact it does because if
you go ahead and you calculate what log
of 0.97 is let's pull up the calculator
here let's go for our functions log 0.97
you might not have anticipated this but
log 0.97 it's a negative number that's
because log natural the base is eight
zero point nine seven is less than a so
if you want a bit of a refresher for why
that would give a negative index I'm
thinking about your power laws and how
you would get a number less than e in
this case zero point nine seven you need
a negative index so when I divide it
through just came back two are working
now when I divided through by a log zero
point nine seven over here I've divided
through by a negative number which means
my inequality it's got a switch signs so
I switch directions I should say so
that's that the really the most cheeky
nasty sort of thing about this okay all
right now once we've gotten to this I
just need to sort of evaluate all this
stuff on the right hand side so what I'm
gonna say n is greater than and actually
I should've left my calculator there
let's pull our calculator open again and
I'm going to evaluate what this ends up
being
so let's see here let's put a division
sign in there that's gross I need that
in the denominator so let's pop this on
the top a numerator is log 0.01 and our
denominator is log zero point nine seven
and I get an answer
151 let's write this down while I can
still see it 150 one point one nine and
some other stuff all right now how do I
interpret this like I've gotten to the
end I've made n the subject of this
inequality but how do I interpret what
this means for the question well what we
set up was this inequality right here we
said this inequality tells us when does
the intensity of light what you know
particular layer we'll get to below 1%
0.01 and what this is telling us is that
so long as you choose a value of n above
150 1.19
you'll have less than 1% light less than
0.01 now I only want a specific number
of sheets the minimum number of sheets
as you can see from the question so I
just need this smallest number that is
greater than 150 1.19 so that would be
there for a hundred and fifty two sheets
of course that's the smallest number
that's hole that satisfies this
inequality so one hundred fifty two
sheets of glass I required all right
so done that is Method one I used it in
equality I just went straight from this
inequality and I took logs of both sides
in order to work with that and the most
sneaky thing that we had to be careful
of was that we had to watch out for
dividing through by this guy because
it's negative so it changes the
direction of our inequality all right so
I was method one now it's true some
people look at that in there like well
that's quite confusing that whole you
know division by that negative log even
though it doesn't look negative there
are no negative signs kind of there this
sort of hidden so is there another way
we can do this that avoids that problem
and the answer is there is what I want
to do rather than treating this as an
inequality
I'm gonna convert the inequality to an
equivalent equation now how do I do that
well what I want to do is and I do know
what the answer is gonna be I've already
worked out what it is but what I want to
do is find when does you know there's a
point at which some value of n before
which you don't have that amount of
glass that's sufficient to reduce the
level of light and then after that is
like a tipping point which which we've
identified over here there's a tipping
point where after that you're fine okay
so what I want to do is find out what is
that tipping point and in order to do
that I can convert my inequality which
was looking like this before is less
than 0.01 I can convert that to an
equation which will allow me to find
what the tipping point is okay so I'm
gonna say instead of lesser than I want
to say equals okay this will give us the
tipping point the the the place where it
changes from not too much light to oh
cool I've got a low enough amount okay
so let's let's solve this let's go ahead
and give this a go now I'm gonna I could
solve it very similar to how I did the
previous one but I to try and flex your
log wall muscles I'm gonna do it a
different way I'm gonna take this
equation which is a an exponential
equation it's something raised to a
power and I'm going to convert this
immediately directly into a log equation
I always have a bit of trouble when I
haven't done this for a while
remembering which of these pieces goes
where in the log equation so I like to
have sort of a go to sort of example of
converting an exponential equation into
a log equation that I can commit to
memory and that I know quite comfortably
and I could check with a calculator so
this is an exponential equation and I
can say it's equivalent X its equivalent
log equation looks like this log base to
the base becomes a base the 32 switches
over to this side log base 2 of 32 it
equals 5 so we make the power the new
subject of the equation so that's what
I'm going to do I'm gonna say all right
let's get rid of these
because they're not helpful to me I'm
gonna say n that's the the power that
was up here before it's gonna be equal
to log base 0.97 the base becomes the
base or 0.01 all right so I want to
solve for n now I can't put this
expression straight into my calculator
because my calculator doesn't have a log
base to 0.97 so I actually have to do
the same thing I end up with the same
thing that I got before by using the
change of base law and the change of
base law tells me I can convert this
space into any base I like by saying and
one which is basically again it's easy
log of the top number this argument over
here is divided by log of the base
so hopefully you recognize this
particular line from when it appeared
over here and the advantage of course
was that because we're dealing with an
equation here and equals not n is
greater than or lesser than I don't have
to change the direction of the
inequality of the equation because an
equation doesn't have a direction both
sides are the same
alright now at this point we actually
already know what this answer is because
we worked it out earlier this is 150
1.19 etc now the danger in using this
method here is that you know especially
if you didn't know what the answer was
because you tried it through some other
method it'll be tempting to say oh I
need to get some whole number for M
because it's a number of sheets of glass
and I've got this number over here so I
guess what I'll do is I'll round and the
closest number to round 2 is 151 now we
already actually know that this is not
the answer because rounding down means
you're going to the sheet of glass
before it's okay we need the sheet of
glass after it's okay but you can
confirm this for yourself just by
testing this out you can say well what
would happen if I did round to 151 what
would I get it would be 0.9 7 ^ 151
going to my calculator over here let's
just punch that in
bracket zero point nine seven and raise
that to the power of a hundred and
fifty-one so what have we got here and
what I've got is zero point zero one
zero zero five eight and then some other
stuff okay
in other words this is one point zero
zero five eight percent dot dot dot and
I don't want above one percent I want
below one percent because I added a pie
in there that was not intentional I was
given that so we can quickly test that
out well what happens when I go to the
next term and this will be handy because
it will confirm the answer we got before
let's change that 151 in the calculator
to 152 so I'm getting now my displays
telling me zero zero nine seven five six
seven and more stuff and if we convert
that to a percentage that's zero point
nine seven five six seven percent and
the rest of it so as we can see this
confirms that I get below one percent by
getting to the 150 second piece of glass
so we've got these are let's get this
calculator the way we are these two
methods right here's the equation and
here's how we got our answer and
confirmed it here's the inequality you
can use either they both arrive at the
same answer but the important thing is
to first establish what your geometric
oppression is that's what all of this
work here is for that was important and
then choose why I think it's important
to know both methods but choose the one
that I think I'm sort of you're more
comfortable with and can do more
reliably it is pretty sneaky each one
has its own danger so make sure you're
able to use both whatever the situation
is